Greetings and welcome to earthlings
cinema.
I am your host Garrick's wormy Lloyd.
This week's artifact is guardians of the
Galaxy Vol,
two starring sexy Labrador retriever,
Chris Pratt and directed by a certified
earthlings cinema Super Fan,
James Gunn.
We open on an unsolicited music video
for electric.
Light Orchestra is Mr Blue Sky,
but shortly thereafter the movie begins.
The space of Andrew's are added again.
Only this time they're on autopilot
because they're rolling in that squeak
well money rocket steals a bunch of car
batteries from a nearby mitis store,
so the midas employees launch a full
scale attack with their drone army.
Fortunately,
at giant hard boiled egg comes along and
saves our heroes without even cracking a
shell.
The captain of the egg introduces
himself as Eggo.
Peter quills,
long lost father and a healthy part of a
balanced breakfast invites everyone back
to his home planet for some extra syrup,
but just the humanoid characters,
the freaks have to stay behind in case
someone shows up to kidnap them,
which thankfully someone does.
It's Yon.
Do a minor bad guy from the first one
here to confuse everybody by snagging
the primary emotional arc of the second
one,
he captures rocket,
but almost immediately his crew mutinies
for fear of getting their trash cans
knocked over,
or the crew doesn't account for his baby
groot coming to the rescue with
Vaudevillian slapstick.
Meanwhile,
Eggo reveals that he and his home planet
are actually one and the same and that
he's some kind of godlike celestial
being a super ego,
if you will.
He explained that he took his Kurt
Russell form in order to travel the
universe and find meaning in his life.
I either get laid,
he does not explain why.
A being who has been around for
Millennia and projects is on appearance,
would bother to age himself up after
only 30 years.
In any case,
echo shows,
Peter,
that he has celestial powers to,
such as the power to have a catch and
the power to overanalyze earth media,
one of earth's greatest musical
compositions.
Perhaps it's very greatest.
Yes.
As if anyone had any interest in that
unfortunately Eggo,
then let slip that he planted seeds on
thousands of planets in order to take
them over,
but one celestial isn't enough to
activate them.
He needs to celestial's.
Why not just do it himself and only
activate half the planets?
You asked?
Shut up.
Peter starts going through his
rebellious phase and stands up to his
mean old dad.
Soon.
All the other space avengers join in on
the fund and rock.
It makes a bomb using those batteries
from the beginning.
Full circle baby.
They burn to a crisp and yon do
sacrifices himself to prove some point
or another.
Then there's just enough time for the
movie to set the Guinness Beer record
for most post credit scene guardians of
the galaxy volume two as an Ode to daddy
issues and all their various forms,
especially the form that leads to lower
back tattoos.
Oh,
of course.
I have issues per Dr.
Sigman Floyd,
the heavyweight champion of
psychoanalysis.
The childhood need for a father's
protection plays a crucial role in
shaping the human psyche.
Even if the shape of that psyche ends up
being a primitive,
a morphous Blob,
Peter has spent his whole life yearning
for the father who abandoned him with
nothing more than an ab roller at a tub
of protein powder,
Gomorrah and nebulous father thanos
forced them to fight each other,
destroying the family bond as well as
nebulous skin to metal ratio.
Every time my sister prevailed,
my father would replace a piece of
machinery rocket.
Never even had any parents to begin
with,
which could be why he never learned to
shave.
I know them.
Scientists.
What made you never gave a rat's ass
about serious?
My own damn parents who saw me,
faith in the slavery,
a character
attempt to overcome their respective
daddy issues by turning into helio
copter,
parents of their collective child,
baby groot.
We're going to need to have a real
discussion about your language.
When we meet ego,
he's draped in long lost father tropes
from the cliche game of catch to having
a beard,
but we soon learned that Eggos
motivations are less about fatherhood
and more about taking over the known
universe,
which is not how most father showed
their love.
Karen's Dad,
this is a radical inflation of
ethicists,
henry the Henry Nader Sedgwick's concept
of ethical egoism,
which states that one ought to act only
out of self interest in order to
maximize their own pleasure eggos.
Self absorption is so crest complete
that all other life pales in comparison.
I told you how all those years ago I had
an unceasing impulse to find life,
but what I did not tell you,
this is how when I finally did find it
was also disappointing.
Hey,
you and me both bow.
The antithesis to Eggos philosophy is
altruism didn't realize your motivation
was altruism.
A term invented by French philosopher
Auguste,
the Henry Nader comped that suggests man
has a moral obligation to live for
others.
One need look no further than the name
guardians of the galaxy vol.
Two,
to detect this idea as the word guardian
implies a duty to protect others and
fall to implies a cynical view of the
movie going.
Public Echo tries to inflate Peter's
pride,
we've heard tell about the man they call
star Lord and tempt him with weird
poetry.
Death will remain a stranger to both of
us as long as the light burns within the
planet,
but the Guardian's vanquish Eggo instead
proving once and for all that altruism
triumphs over selfishness well twice and
for all,
since they pretty much did the same
thing at the end of all,
one for earthlink cinema,
I am groot.
I mean Garrick's formula.
Goodbye.
If you have the film analysis fuzzies,
check out our friend Lee over at cinema
winds.
He focuses on the great stuff behind
movies,
covering everything from Scott pilgrim
to marijuana to the dark knight.
Click here to watch his latest video,
everything great about guardians of the
galaxy,
volume two,
and click here to visit his channel page
and be sure to subscribe while you're
there.
See you next time.
Earth enthusiastic.
It's goodbye.